après plusieurs semaines durant
lesquelles les rebondissements autour de
la vie de philippe winter faisait
quotidiennement par les la presse people
voilà que ces derniers jours tout le
monde avait perdu la trace de la
chanteuse avant ce nouveau scandale il
ya quelques semaines plusieurs magazines
dévoilé une réalité bien triste la
descente aux enfers de la star des
années 90 ophélie winter
après une carrière en dents de scie ces
dernières années une séparation à dubaï
de retour en france la jeune femme
s'était retrouvé sdf semble-t-il obligé
de passer certains soirs dans sa voiture
par chance ces derniers jours la
situation semblait s'être arrangé grâce
à l'argent d'un proche et aux quelques
économies qui lui reste et ophélie avait
posé ses valises dans un hôtel de luxe
non loin des champs elysées mais là
encore un grain de sable est venu
enrayer cette douce remonter d'après les
informations de voici la police a dû
intervenir en urgence à cet hôtel pour
calmer ophélie prise d'une crise de
démence
elle se serait mise à hurler et à tout
casser autour d'elle elle criait que
quelqu'un voulait la tuer cette violente
crise de paranoïa a fait grand bruit
dans les couloirs du chic hôtel parisien
qui lui a demandé de bien vouloir partir
si désormais ses problèmes financiers
semblent temporairement derrière elle
les amis de la chanteuse se sont assuré
qu'elles soient en permanence accompagné
d'un chauffeur/garde du corps inquiet de
sa fragilité psychologique
bernard qu'est ce qu'on pense d'eux ça
toi alors taux n'est pas faux en réalité
ça va mieux et heureusement
effectivement là je crois qu'elle a fait
est en train de taper sur un de ces
comptes qu'elle avait et c'est pour
l'argent donc ça va mieux elle vit
effectivement dans un hôtel dans le 8e
qui est un très bel hôtel
elle a effectivement quelqu'un qui la
suit maintenant qui la protège un peu
parce qu'effectivement elle a des crises
de paranoïa où elle pense qu'on va la
tuer ce qu'il faut mais c'est un
problème
et puis avec quelqu'un de malfaisants
qui appelle hôtel régulièrement et qui
envoyait les flics en disant allez vite
vous occuper d'elle ça va pas du tout
aux qualités 13 emmerder que cette
histoire c'est vrai qu'elle a décrite
parfois de parano mais ça va mieux ça se
passe mieux et l'actuel il mais qui
s'occupe d'elle c'est l'ancien garde du
corps de gilbert montagné d'ailleurs qui
d'un mec extrêmement sympathique
s'appelle pascal c'est du détail
intéressant parce que c'est écrit nulle
part pas gary quince un labrador
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gilbert qui est puis à faire des déçus
il y avait quelqu'un de bruit ce que
j'adore gilbert way danger mais avec
tout le monde adore gilbert qui attaque
et gilbert en fait il y avait des mecs
qui attaque et gilbert mon nom mais les
artistes sont souvent à garder encore un
garde du corps pour conduire pour leur
mental est au mieux une assistance aux
personnes handicapées le fragiliser bien
sûr non mais c'est ça fait voilà
assistant oui moi j'ai envie de vous
demander qui peut en vouloir à ophélie
winter
enfin c'est débile se fédèrent enfin je
me suis fait pas débile de prendre un
garde du corps c'est complètement débile
d'en vouloir à quelqu'un vous en savez
peut-être lassé des mauvais choix tu
sais pas du fait qu'elle a effectivement
des ennemis bah oui il est justement de
là bernard celle avait repris des
rapports avec son frère face à l'eire
après que sa famille commencé en ce
moment donc c'est vraiment toujours pas
drapeau rouge avait entonné que son
frère chercher à la protéger oui bien
sûr sa mère aussi mais bon il n'y a pas
de rapport du tout ça c'est clair non
revanche ce qui est important c'est que
quelqu'un s'amuse ap l'hôtel en disant
il ya le bordel dans la chambre à l'isie
et c'est ce qu'il faut et cette personne
là je ne sais pas qui c'est envoyer les
flics régulièrement le tessin et rural
boyle avait demandé de partir
heureusement ça s'est arrangé ils ont
compris que la cette fois ci c'est pas
elle que ça allait très bien avec
quelques crises comme de parano comme on
l'a dit c'est vrai ça mais tout va mieux
ça ça se passe très bien voilà qui me
fait bizarre que je suis pas du tout
dans leur vie c'est ça que ça a lâché ce
couteau parce qu'il ya un mois dormaient
dans sa smart la trouver des sous sur un
compte
elle va dans un hôtel luxueux sur les
champs elysées à ta mère tu trouves ton
un petit truc sympathique en banlieue et
arrose ses toiles inscrire dans un envoi
la revoir encore massmart
au patron vincent l'hôtel de luxe en
larmes elle a des amis qu'il est aussi
marquée mais non mais elle va mieux elle
va mieux il ya des rams et des amis
qu'il est dans la vie dont les amis
qu'il aide son appel qui paye à la
baisse on va attendre